what's really hard  is getting that you know that loyal  status getting a customer who sort of  won't pick up the phone to anyone else  but you that takes a long time what are  the principles to get into that point i  think the principles to get into that  point for me are about talking to  someone not because you've got something  not because you need something but just  because you care about that person i  have so many customers now i mean you  can only have so many relationships that  are this strong but i've probably got 20  relationships with people that i would  genuinely say are almost you know  professional friends right i know their  kids names i know i know they like to at  the weekends that stuff takes a lot of  time to get there you've got to add  value to them professionally you've got  to show an interest in who they are both  professionally and personally and you've  got to keep in touch with them  [Music]